cool so thanks for uh joining us for the
last session of the day uh we're gonna
have two talks
and the first talk uh we're excited to
have uh kai cheng zhang who's going to
be talking about his work on
uh independent learning in uh stochastic
games so i'll let you uh take it away
all right thank you very much
actually thank you very much for the
invitation it's really my great pleasure
to be here to present our work so if you
notice today i'm going to talk about
independent learning in stochastic games
which was the title i proposed but then
uh then i realized that i may have to
emphasize something different which is
even greater than that
uh so part here so i will explain more
what do i mean by that and what's the
difference
so uh this is a joint work mainly with
muhammad tamel and asu
so i believe all the whole like workshop
has set up the stage for me so i don't
have to introduce more about this
background so we know that rl has
achieved tremendous empirical successes
in application domains like playing go
games playing video games or even
robotic control
therefore there has been actually a
resurgence of interest in the
theoretical understanding of reinforced
learning and why it works
if you take a look at most of the
application scenarios here they
naturally involve more than one decision
makers or more than one agent
for example in playing gold games there
are two players playing
against each other or the video games i
just
mentioned some other examples include
like robot motion planning or autonomous
driving
therefore
all these applications has motivated a
great line of recent works on multi and
rl and if you just check the schedule of
the workshop here you'll notice they're
just a lot even the titles that look so
similar to each other and there is a
very
like a a great line of recent works it's
very exciting
in fact usually this uh uh
this motivation our problems is started
under the general framework of markov
games or stochastic games which was
first proposed by sharply back in 50s
and it's a very natural generalization
of a markov decision process which was
the standard model for single agent
reinforced learning a general relation
of that to the multi-agent settings
in fact this was the framework that
opened up this whole area of multi-agent
rl
dated back to little mass work in 90s
however before we talk more about
multi-genre we may want to ask a
question why
do we study multigen reinforcing
learning
or
i found this very foundational and
intriguing question
seems to be very like you know relevant
to this topic is like
uh you have asked like more than a
decade ago
if multi-agent learning is the answer
or is it something we are studying
what is the actual question
is it faster equilibrium computation or
even its computational complexity
or it is about the polynomial sample and
space complexity or you want to achieve
some sublinear regret against some
adversarial opponent
or it is about like less literate
convergence or stable equilibrium
learning dynamics or start elastic
convergence to the equilibrium
or another question is more like alphas
in another way is find the equilibrium
all we need or always have got
in fact one traditional explanation of
equilibrium is that it results from
analysis and introspection by the
players
knowing the rules of the game the
rationality of the players and the pair
functions
there are great examples like we have
learned from many game theory textbooks
like princess dilemma or battle of sexes
that's how we interpret equilibrium
however there is a in the in the
literature there are slightly different
point of view which is in the learning
and games literature and this is a very
nice
book
that started this area
basically they interpreted equilibrium
in a different way
they said equilibrium arises as a
long-run outcome of a process
in which less than fully rational
players group 4 group for optimality
over time
i'll explain a little bit more what that
means in the next several slides
for example equilibrium is not the
target
instead it is the natural outcome of
some myopic
and non-equilibrium learning dynamics
this perspective has been well
established in the normal form game or
static game setting
and this book summarized almost all the
literature on this topic
as this perspective also choose
stochastic games with state dynamics
that was the question we would like to
answer or that was actually the question
that motivates this line of work
this perspective of studying long-run
behavior favors the use of infinite
horizon stochastic games which is
exactly the model proposed by sharply
back in 50s
and in fact even random stochastic games
as a textbook setting with broad
applications economics political science
and operations research
another way to look at it is like it can
be viewed as a generalization of evenly
repeated game which we know it's hard to
solve it by backwarding touch induction
it's just infinitely repeating the same
game
or
on the other direction if it's not the
case in general
maybe it is fine to just embrace this
learning dynamics
if i interested feel free to check this
very uh very uh
illuminating talk by crystals on
impression of game dynamics
basically
we can even define new solution concepts
based on dynamics or they call it just
like the dynamics show you the way you
don't have to always be targeting at
funny equilibrium
on the other hand in multi-agent
reinforced learning
so there is something called independent
learning
basically it means that each agent just
runs variants of some single agent
reinforcement algorithms
to myopically improve their policies
sometimes even be oblivious to other
agents or even the type of the game
and technically this type of method of
independent learning is known to suffer
from convergence issues
for example
condoms paper mentioned that if you just
independently run kind of policy
iteration algorithm for zero sum two
player game as stochastic games you
cannot converge
to the equilibrium
there may be some other like examples of
convergence issues
uh in some other like stochastic game
settings
the key challenge here is something
called non-stationarity issue
we are from one single agent's
perspective
the environment is always changing
because other agents are also learning
and adapting their policies
therefore it breaks the very important
assumption which is the stationarity
market decision process assumption
that has been used to analyze the
convergent convergence of single agent
reinforced learning that's why it's very
hard to make this independent learning
dynamics converge
however in practice people have observed
that
independent learning seems to perform
pretty well at least it's better than
expected
there are some very like recent and the
very very uh interesting work talking
about maybe independent learning is all
you need in playing starcraft
multi-agent challenge
or they study the surprising effects of
ppo which is proximal policy
authorization incorporating multiple
games
or they also use independent algorithms
and they show that accurate can perform
on par with multi-leading ones
incorporate in both cooperative and
competitive settings
now they have even implemented this
decentralized rl
control of a robotic manipulator and
they achieve pretty good performance
the question of interest is
the perspective perspective mentioned
for like static sorry questions
statement seems to perform well
yeah so in this examples most of the
cases they are starting a cooperative
setting so when they say perform well
they just implement the policy they
learn and they achieve higher like total
i mean the the reward than
comparative cooperative setting yes
but there are also but of course like
there are also some competitive settings
then probably they are competing with
some
uh player or some some opponent that
either use a fixed policy or some
minimax policy but still they have a
american type of performance there
i just didn't know what you meant i mean
this is embarrassing
what did you mean by multi-agent ones so
you have independent algorithms
what's up an example of multi-agent
yes exactly
uh also by the way these are all the
posts from all these papers yeah there's
multiple games i think it's just a
competitive like still hasn't it i don't
know and then multi-agent refers to
learning
i mean
the whole the whole the whole workshop
is about this but i just didn't know
what it meant in that sense
independent algorithms can perform on
par with multi-agents
oh yeah so i guess here what they mean
is that they have some sometimes in the
market especially in the deep
multidisciplinary literature they have
something called centralized training
and decentralized execution meaning that
in the training phase they can't collect
all the information from the agent to do
a centralized training i think probably
that's what it means by multi agent ones
so yeah so sometimes from that paper so
but i guess that's what it means it's
very practical actually they use a
centralized training and stress
execution
protocol to to train this multi-agent
deeper methods
um
so our question is can this equilibrium
in stochastic games be realized by
myopic and independent learning dynamics
infinite horizons stochastic games
if so in some cases
then it might be in turn justify the
success of independent learning
in multilateral in certain
cases and if not
in general
is there any possible like fundamental
reasons for that
so i guess i don't need to introduce
this background because many of the
talks has talked about this
uh setting basically here we consider
infinite horizon stochastic game setting
s is a state space
ai is action space of player i
and ri is a reward function of player i
which is affected by the state s and the
drawn action of all the
players
if you are considering a two player zero
sum setting the n is equal to two and
the other rewards sum up to zero
like playing gold game is one example of
that but this is even have this game has
even more structure because this is kind
of like a turn-based game as some of the
previous talks has talked about
and also there is a p here denotes the
the like the state transition dynamics
meaning that the transition of the state
is affected by the joint action of all
the agents
and gamma here is the discount factor
that lies between zero to one
it's very similar to the like even
horizon discounted markov decision
process model we're familiar with in
single identity
the solution we are looking for is nash
equilibrium
for short basically we are considering
markov stationary nash equilibrium
where pi i is a set of policies for each
state it is a mixed strategy
over the actions that agent i can take
if you put all the pi together that's a
strategy profile that's a joint strategy
of all the players
also it's stationary in the sense that
it's mark of venus is that it only
depends on the current state
it is stationary meaning that it's not
time varying
now we can define the expected value
function of player i
which is basically the expected
long-term accumulated discontent a
reward starting from state s
then by saying markov station not
equilibrium will mean that if you
confirm such a markov stationary
strategy profile pi star which is a
joint strategy it is a nash equilibrium
providing that for all states
there's no incentive for the agent
to deviate from it and from the
literature we know that there always
exists
such a equilibrium for even rather than
discounters to cast games
although one thing to note is that this
value functions has a very complicated
dependence on the policies as in general
is a non-concave
game
but amazingly this nash equilibrium
always exists
our main result here is to show that
actually independent learning
some very simple dynamics can work
we identify simple best response type of
dynamics with convergence guarantees to
the nash equilibrium in certain
stochastic games
the learning dynamics requires no
coordination among agents
it is magic
and we believe it is natural
in fact each agent in this dynamics each
agent is unaware of the type of the game
whether it's a zero-sum game or not a
zero-sum game
and sometimes even unaware of the
existence of other agents
so
the game sorry the algorithm we're
proposing is called decentralized q
learning it's a small modification of
the independent q learning algorithms
and there's some independent learning
without knowing the opponents
so basically we want to develop some our
goal is to try to try to develop some
fast response type of learning dynamics
while the action or even the action set
of the opponent cannot be observed
so in addition to the value function i
defined before we also define something
called the local queue function
which is just the queue function
marginalized with respect to the
opponent
strategy
therefore this local queue function is
only going to be a function of the state
and the action of player i this could be
this is some quantity that you can just
maintain by yourself by agent i
there are two steps in the dynamics
so first step is that the player i
infer the opponent's strategy because
she cannot observe directly observe the
play of the opponent
she will infer the opponent's strategy
by estimating the local queue function
qi
how to do that
so we take a very similar step as a
single agent to learn at the rule
this is what we propose
so if you're familiar with uh
uh
if you learn update well this looks very
similar i'll introduce next how
different how it's different from that
so basically you maintain this uh
temporal difference arrow here and alpha
here is a step size
and the action here is shown from some
smooth pass response with respect to
this local q function
so this new here is some perturbation
function
and uh tau here is some temp temperature
parameter we can control
so you can choose this new eye to be for
example a
a entropy function then this arc max
will give you a soft max
it's what invests most best response
in contrast to the vanilla independent
killer and if you run this algorithm
independently this is what in my
independent queue learning so basically
replace this vi here which is the
quantity i'm going to introduce in the
next slide
by taking a max over the current local
estimate of the sorry estimate of the
local queue function if you do this this
is reduces to the vanilla like
independent q learning algorithm
but instead we take a different route we
use a different variable here we had
instead
the first line says the action set of
the opponent cannot be observed
you know what the set is you know the
opponent is there and what they're
saying is you just don't know what they
did is that what you're saying yeah i
don't know what they did
so
the word set yeah but you don't need to
know the set when you implement this
algorithm
uh
okay yeah this is just an adjuster this
adjusts something on the tent locally
and then you'll start the local small
status response
with respect to the local qr uh
you are estimating
is this stuff in the brackets
everything in the
oh not really oh yeah
well you have d-hat in purple there and
then i don't know well this is new sorry
this is a perturbation function so then
where is the yes here
so this is the first step so we're
trying to the starting point is now
we're trying to see
where it breaks or whether we can modify
a little bit of just independent
learning to make it work so we make this
more modification
another update we we had
you know different like
uh uh update rule basically we use the
expected value of with respect to the
smooth space response
and we maintain that we have this random
variable like separately
so note that all the quantities i just
introduced are maintained locally
without coordination or communication
among agents
any questions
sir
you just do a very myopic way in the
sense that oh as if you don't know the
environment i don't know humans there
are some other agents
adjustments it's not random variable and
they'll take the best response that
yep yes
so if you have like q values
why
yeah that's a good question because
actually if you just maybe just like
this just around this it may not
converge
number two you have like
so it's a different variable program and
turning a separate time scale to kind of
stabilize
the dynamics
okay
but you could use also like another q
value and
expect there may be possibility of that
but yeah we didn't do that
so this out there you can do it locally
and this is like a summary of this
learning dynamics there are several
features of this learning dynamics
it's kind of natural for self-interested
players because
it is as if solving a singularity
problem melodically an object is
symmetric
coordination free on the communication
frame
another feature of the of the of the
dynamics is that it is two times scale
in the sense that
in the limit
the dynamics sorry
oh sure
so in the first line this is
which is on a different side
yeah bar is the most fast response but
we want to make it like
best response type of dynamics i believe
this is natural dynamics so we we're
building upon this move that is not
physically antibiotic
and actually suffer from this fiber
and then we do this terminal difference
kind of
but instead of doing this we uh mentor a
different like uh random variable here
and then we mentioned this we updated
this we had different uh
[Music]
yes i don't change others i just
update this specific api
it's like a traditional synchronous
asynchronous killer
is that instead of just taking the
maximum q value of the next state you
successfully maintain an e
yes state and you might in the update
figure
okay so now the feature is two times
square and since that is a limit
the start size of doing the second one
which is cloud and value function is
lower than update of the local queue
function
and then the
intuition here is that then by doing
that your the first dynamics is as if
you are solving a matrix game
or a normal form game
with this payoff matrix
so basically p is a transition dynamics
if you recall so as let's say if the
stab size of beta is very very small
compared to the first one then basically
this is relatively stationary we are
kind of creating a stationary
environment for the first update this is
as if solving a normal form game with
this new payoff matrix
and also interestingly we found some
some kind of justification for this
two-time scale dynamics
basically
they argue that usually in practice
players choices are more dynamic than
their preferences what we mean here is
that the v here can be viewed which is
like the estimate of value function of
yourself it's kind of like the
preference you have but based on this
preference you may make more dynamic or
change your choices of the uh
actions more frequently or more dynamic
than the changes of the value function
let's kind of justify this two time
scale kind of dynamics
and also this note that this by doing
this you don't have to know uh the
presence of the opponent nor be aware of
the structure of the game it is zero sum
or not doesn't matter
this is something in the learning games
literature especially for um learning
static games they called radically on
carpool dynamics
or something sometimes they called
payoff based dynamics you only rely on
the payoff you receive here
to do that it's called the radically
uncoupled
although in rl literature which seems to
be not motivating our literature is not
seems to be not using that uh very much
and then the the the result first result
we have is that if you if if both
players run this decentralized q
learning
dynamics
in zero in zero sums to castle games
they will converge to the nash
equilibrium of the game
the value will convert the vr
we had estimate will converge to the
restart
and also if you if you take a with it
alpha c here is the step size if you
take weighted average of the policy or
smooth batch response policy you
encounter during learning it will
convert to nash equilibrium of this zero
sums to case again
more importantly actually there was a
work back in uh 2001
proposed that a desirable multiagent rl
algorithm should be not only convergent
meaning that it will convert to some
good equilibrium to some equilibrium but
also it should be rational
the way they define being rational is
that the iterates of one player
converges to the opponent's best
response if the opponent converges to
some stationary policy that's a very
desired property of multiple algorithms
because in this case meaning that this
dynamics dynamics can kind of exploit a
weaker opponent
therefore it is rational for the agent
to even follow this dynamics in the
first place
that was the reason why they called
irrational
and what we can show is that
our decentralized curating dynamics is
rational
if the opponent converges asymptotically
to some stationary strategy
then this dynamics will converge to the
best response respect to it
basically it's related to first our step
size has to satisfy the roman condition
and also they have to test that this
two-time scale uh assumption and also
you need to assume some some kind of
like reachability of the states
it's like the standard one that you have
in the convergence of single agent
converting that kind of thing that's a
little bit tricky than that so i have
the backup slides and later we can
discuss i'll find that yeah that's
basically that
um my second question was if i
understand like you're upgrading the
values the values that's slower than the
power system and this is a bit different
yeah it's like the two times
approximation there's only one time
scale but this is like a two-time scale
it's also compensating
it's just
there are two different time stores and
that makes a nicest work challenge yeah
it can be a business right sure
yeah i um
i'm running a little bit uh a lot of
time i mean briefly introduce how do i
do that how many times
okay sure
um basically idea to show the
convergence of this learning dynamics is
that we connect this learning dynamics
to some continuous time
uh ode
and then we construct a newly optimal
function to show the convergence
so basically in the first step we
rewrite this lower time scale of this v
hat in this form
and then basically this ti here is the
minimax value iteration of operator
which has a very nice contracting
property
has been shown actually in the sharpies
very first work
and then from the stochastic
approximation theory we know that
actually the v hat will co the
difference between this v head and the v
star will be bounded by the limb support
this additional arrow here and then
right now we'll focus on quantifying
this
uh limit which is something we call the
tracking arrow
and then because of these two time scale
step sizes we can rewrite
we can we can characterize the update
rule by this ode
basically it's like the v
update is almost stationary for this q
update
and then we zoom into the faster time
scale
as if this we had a vi here are
stationary
another way like if if let's say the the
qr here is just of this form where it's
if there exists some big qi which is
global qi
and uh times this opponent strategy if
this small qr happens to have this
structure then actually this equivalent
to the smooth special best response
dynamics
so analysis
however this is not always the case
therefore we kind of have to lift the
dimension of this ode to study this new
od
and then finally we this is a
function we are designed for this method
and the key challenge here is that
because they are doing independent
learning
although the game by nature is a zero
sum game but the queue
you are using during the learning
process may not be zero sum anymore
but we show we managed to show using
this natural function that
asymptotically it will be zero sum
and also what we might not believe basis
exactly like this so this qi may not be
like in this very nice like product form
there may not exist such a qi such that
a small qr is a product of qi and the
opponent's strategy that was the key
challenges that we addressed in
developing this kind of complicated
laptop function
and then i uh
and then we zoom out to the uh a slower
time scale to show that actually this
outer loop v hat will converge because
of the uh contracting property of this
operator
i'm happy to talk more offline if you're
interested about this kind of analysis
note that uh there exists some two-time
scale so stochastic approximation theory
but most of the assumptions here are not
satisfied by this by our learning
dynamics therefore these proofs are new
and of independent interest even for
this two-time scale stochastic
approximation theory
there are some very simple uh numeric
examples to show the convergence of this
learning dynamics
let me quickly uh summarize and uh see
uh to to conclude my talk
so i guess the question in addition to
that is how far can we go about
independent learning
for stochastic games especially infinite
violence to castle games
so there is something in the literature
in learning on games called fictitious
play property
and
something we call the game agnostic
convergence i'll explain now
because one desired property of
independent learning in addition to
being like natural and myopic and
leading to some equilibrium
this game organized a scheme type
agnostic
one example is fictitious play
a very natural dynamics it converges in
several different types of normal form
games
a game has
has this kind of fictitious player
probability if the fictitious player
converges in these types of games so
it's equilibrium
what about stochastic games does there
exist the castle games that have this
fictitious play property
lately what we have been we have been
able to show is that if you use this
kind of fictitious play dynamics for
stochastic games basically following the
decentralized q learning idea i just
mentioned you first maintain belief of
the opponent's
strategy
by just
right now by the way will allow the
observation of the opponent's action
you can yield this observation of the
opponent's action to maintain a belief
of the opponent's strategy it's a very
natural way of doing things
and then you plug in this belief into
your local cure
into your q update here
and of course you also need to use this
two-time scale separation
an ai here is taken just as the best
response with respect to this q hat you
maintain and the belief of the opponent
you maintain you do this very natural
like best response
dynamics
and this very same factitious plate
dynamics
converge to nash equilibrium for both
their sum which show that for both zero
sum and unplayer single controller
identical interest
stochasa games
which is a cooperative setting
so this dynamic good thing about this
dynamics is that you don't need to know
the agent does not need to know what
type of game you are playing
therefore we show that these two at
least these two types of stochastic
games have this fictitious play property
and also more recently we showed that a
variant of independent and symmetric
policy-graded method
which you can view it as a better
response independent learning dynamics
also converges in more than two types of
sorry more than one type of stochastic
games including the zero sum setting and
identical interest setting
although infinite quantum general sum
actually there is a very nice work by
a zinc bridge greenwald and litman back
in 2005 but actually they showed that
for general some stochastic games i
think i also feel like this work is kind
of underappreciated i think it's a very
nice work actually they show that the
value equation based method of
value-based method cannot find
stationary equilibrium in general some
stochastic games
also our decentralized q learning cannot
either because if you recall the way we
show the
convergence is strongly dependent on the
gamma contracting property of the
minimax value iteration but zero some
stochastic games which breaks in the
general sum case
in fact it's unclear how to construct a
stationary equilibrium from
non-stationary ones
because it's not like single-editing
setting you can just do the truncation
and do the value iteration to pick the
first
like the strategy at time one
as a good approximation of the
stationary solution for the whole
problem you cannot do that here because
there's no such a nice property of this
value iteration operator in games in
general some case
so questions are interesting is there a
fundamental reason why infinite horizon
general sums to cancel games are
challenging
there might be one actually if you
haven't please check nora's talk on our
recent results on the harness of finding
mark of stationary equilibrium any kind
of equilibrium like nash correlated
chorus correlated in general some
stochastic games
even in the two pair case
also see also the concurrent work uh
talked about by a video in uh
yesterday's talk
if you lack this stationary requirement
but still keep the microphone part
we have a decentralized learning
algorithm
with polynomial dependence on all the
parameters including the number of
agents
so uh to summarize
um we start the independent
multi-general infinite horizon
stochastic games which was the original
model proposed by sharply
there are several takes away takeaways
so if multi-agent rl is a is the answer
so maybe justifying whether the
equilibrium can be realized by myopic
natural and independent non-equilibrium
adaptation dynamics might be one
question
in addition to many others like the
sample and computational complexity
regret all the convergence speed
also by using this kind of two-time
scale time step
step size separation
we were able to show that decentralized
q learning can converge
although
although in general they may suffer from
non-stationarity issues
and also fake pictures play property and
also this game agnostic kind of
converges which is a very nice property
this decentralized or independent
learning dynamics have
exist in stochastic games
and family infinite horizon stochastic
games could have sharpened fundamental
differences from finite horizon games
and even for mdps with many open
problems
with that i would like to conclude and i
have been privileged to
take part in writing some of the
automatic chapters on this topic and
also i strongly recommend the blog post
if you haven't checked
by channel on this recent progress on
multi-genara
and thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks a lot
uh let's see are there any questions
kevin
thanks i i really liked the talk it
seems like important work but
i uh
i guess as a remark i'd love to
understand the decentralized q learning
better i feel like there's a simpler
story than the one that you told but i'm
going to try to find out afterwards sure
but
using it in practice is it really
possible to get the the um two-time
scale separation um to happen the way
that you assume formally or do you when
you when you run it in practice you know
do you have to make the second time
scale much slower but not so slow that
the limit would be zero the way that you
wrote it
and if if i'm right then you can't
really separate them asymptotically the
way you
wanted to what would that mean
in practice yeah that's a very good
question so obviously in practice you
mean run by like review agents i mean
like actually run on the computer yeah i
think
you can just do it by choosing
some different steps if i'm talking
about the running by like with human
beings that's something would have to be
just you can really achieve this
separation yes yes we do that
so you just use for example as a step
size full of faster times guys like
okay and then the step size for like the
would you ever want to bring them closer
together if the game is really big and
you're concerned about the
yeah
yeah exactly the bad thing about this
two-time scale is that it may converge
very slowly and actually we have the
experiments showing that even if you
choose the step size to be very close or
even the same it makes it
some
let's see uh maybe we can take one more
question and then go on to the next talk
in the interesting time
um have you thought at all about
approximating this using a deep neural
network similar to dqn is to tabular
queue learning yeah that's a very good
question that's something where i
looking to
hope to have some characters
but in general this uh learning with
functional animation is a hard problem
let's say catching again it's awesome
work
and yeah so the last speaker of the
session and the last week of the day is